hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I am currently starving so I need to
do something about that so I wonder if
soda can actually help me and I wonder
if this will get rotten if I leave it
but I don't know hopefully not drink
amazing alright so I got some soda Amy
did help keep me say she ate it for a
while longer looking deep into the
mirror Oh
deep into the beer okay so the mirror
returns you to the mirror that you came
from it always goes home but it always
goes back to the one you came from okay
so that's good to know
let me out of here what who said that
the girl's voice she hot
sounded like it's coming from that far
wall handgun in which is the kicker
hello hello yeah
I don't like you how did you get in here
are you okay how can I get you out who
did this to you anyway why did you come
here I never wanted you to find me not
like this not like this what do you mean
never been here before who are you
anyway yeah that's right I'm no one
so leave me alone wait I just said that
so wait what she seems familiar some
wait what yeah what's wrong with me
oh don't spaz out again not now okay
why okay hey what's that there's a
business card on the floor I wonder what
that's doing there really now the
director acquisitions etc frequency
102.5 Oh dingo and the baby I guess
that's a radio frequency I'll check it
out next time I visit the radio all
right then I guess 102.5 dingo and the
baby come out alive okay going this room
here and then here turn off my light
when I go in there
Joey's a spacer so uh gotta be a way
around him right it's always a
non-violent solution that's what it said
so hungry damn it keep feeding you and
you keep getting hungry
what is it like a baby always with your
way oh I'm hungry
when feed me I'm a baby I can't even
help myself but eat it
not bad cold actually all right
hopefully that'll hold you for a few a
little bit longer before your big baby
news comes out look a toddler comes up
to me and Luke - hungry haven't eaten in
days
shut up and toughen up a bit yes Ram
babies
alright so there's one right there don't
wanna get go am I gonna have to play
them we're gonna have to old goody goody
gumdrops see I can barely see when
there's a hiding indentation I may not
try try so hard I can see my little
shifty eyes in the dark day ok finally
making it to my destination so my place
is just through that other door I should
probably get some rest while I'm here
why unlock did it last 9 get back to
home a lot easier that's good
the magical mirror portals weren't good
enough how are you even securing here
man hey wait
ok I just slipped yeah I see it yep but
I'm back home so I should at least use
the radio 102.5 the dado on the baby
I've got something special in store for
you today inquire within
apartment 204
ah some dumb Dame right about that goo
for us at the end of the hallway
pretty sure dad door was locked for who
I wish I could pick which mirror I come
out of but apparently NAT alright so
anyway I'm gonna go out my front door
gonna go to the right
gonna put the meet at the end of hide
meet down here not the delicious damn
the rotting meat place the running mate
I'm gonna need to get some more soon I
think I only got three left after that
one
they Heidi the awesome guy here hello
you're looking awfully swell today is it
all the protein you're getting from the
meat you're eating is a dead one
i-it's weird other dead ones just kind
of stay there like the dead bodies don't
go away it's always evident to those
evidence of what I've done you are
creepy it doesn't like you
please leave my honey go for okay Spain
someone's unlocked it alright then what
do we have here oh I wonder who put
these here I wonder who she is it's it's
supposed to be the same girl found them
in what have you got for me
dead cast these the whole rooms covered
with chalk pictures a girl with wings
heart and clouds
some kind of gas tank oh cool
that means I can cook my food yeah there
was the option I saw to cook food but I
just wasn't able to do it woman ow
I'm gonna run out of batteries again
where am I now
where the hell my what no this is a lie
what hi
there's a box you're the Box head guy
man am i pleased to see you what's your
name friend some call me the director I
couldn't tell you why how did you
survive in here there's nothing even in
this apartment I have my ways and means
may even be able to help some well I'd
take a little time to think on how I
survived first oh you didn't what do you
mean
exactly we put I give up you're telling
me you're some kind of survival and for
all I know you're not even real you got
a lotta nerve you know hold on a minute
I've been seeing all kinds of things I
don't know if it's the disease that's
doing that I'm only alive because I
holed up in my apartment how about you
huh I have no idea how you survived well
I could be part of your furtive
imagination I couldn't rightly say but I
reckon I'm here alright sure as the
night is long
but as far as survival goes oh wait this
is the director folks used to say it's
all about keeping your brain in shape
it's still learning myself you'll keep -
you'll learn - in time yes sir yes sir
II Cullen now collar number nine anyway
listen here I like to forage for things
got some I don't have much use for
here's a cooking pot it may be able to
help you sup in fact you can have this
saucepan and I may have more good stuff
for you later to keep your ears on the
radio kid if you catch my meaning now
I'll be seeing you sorry ya voice
probably knowing we're all in this
together just like most radio jockeys
are kind of annoying with her dingo and
the baby thirty point five five thirty
point point five you know you know that
radio station okay so I found everything
in here the music is actually really
nice new that's one of the things that I
have to admit why is there hiding spot
here I have to admit like in this game
it's really cool because like the music
is really intense and the sounds like
that was a freaking cheerful place it
like changed up the entire mood of it
like the director like just relaxing ik
oh are you living on the baby you know
this is very cool
how are you living damn it I gotta blame
him
we know how do i oh isn't there a mirror
in here no there's no mirror in here but
there is a mirror over right about we
knew it at the end of this hallway
that's right okay no I'm big Eric this
mirror over here
there's always another way look deeply
into the mirror
you're looking good friend you're
looking real good don't worry about how
what other people think you now now that
I got the saucepan I can go into my
kitchen I need to eat something so uh
let's uh cook up some grub my stove
don't remember but it ran out of gas
okay so I got see here there we go
use plays it swapped out the old one now
you cook stuff no it's the best news
ever you'd find something suitable to
cook no not the map MA
all right we're gonna cook this rice
pudding get this worse
mmm smells good yeah that's good
that's pot rice pudding it's a winner
all right let's see it it can combine
that with something hey it's like a
whole eating simulator they'll taste
great and it's filling and high comfort
food at its finest well hot damn I've
known awesome I'm surviving
can I sleep now you didn't say it was
tired so I'm assuming he's gonna be okay
all right finally we can go outside of
the UH the apartments here let's see
what we got got a bag of prawn crackers
I don't know thinking come mine knows
but me Vic
all right cooked that I can probably
mine it with something though it's a new
batteries are
all right new map map of winged Court f1
map
all right so I need to go there where
the hills here streams the back alley is
marked on it okay the front door is just
around the corner from here though he's
probably blocked up and I got to go
through another hole I'm guessing okay
going 101 start our crazy adventure here
bottle of milk hope it's long life yeah
hope so I may want to pasteurize at
ground espresso powder as I drink that
espresso and there's another mirror
alright so 101 has everything blocked up
though
101 only has a mirror in it but that's
useful on its own they did it there's a
hiding spot in there I see it but I
think I see it anyway it's probably it
might not be hiding but man the sound is
really good here because I can actually
hear it going farther away no it's not
dry wet yeah uh what do i do I got a
plan them and yes I call I got a plan
him let's see what I'm doing here but hi
are you [ __ ] come on gonna get you oh
ma I love this guy's little shoveling
but but what whoa I'm ditching weirdo
why
minute gap it wasn't with me that close
I'm here I'm gonna blame you adipose key
and then one enough Stacy oh god damn it
damn it
flash Nikes I should have saved Oh Gabe
over no but hope no but I never there oh
no no I still have saved I didn't ah god
damn it ah
I know blue I have please tell me I
still have the pot I don't even have the
pot pot yeah digging I don't even have
the frequency for the director what did
I do
ah screwed up everything PS all right
I'll be back in a second dad
okay rise and shine everyone we're
finally back with dingo and the baby in
the morning now I'm gonna stop doing
ever now but man that was dumb of me to
do but I'm finally back to the other
place that I wasn't um I think instead
of giving me a saucepan the guy gave me
uh oh no wait I do have a saucepan
that's right that's right okay so I do
have a saucepan but he also gave me some
cheese crackers and sliced cheese a lot
of them too so I've got all that which
would be totally awesome and gonna help
me because apparently he realized how
much I suck and games in general however
I am still gonna press on now what I
need to do is not totally ass up
everything in this game I'm gonna go
down the other hallway too because it
seemed like that one was rather
unsuccessful for me it doesn't matter
how cool ah what is that didn't follow
me pick up a baby a man a bucket a house
but we can hide here what does that mean
good the hanging meat we seem to have
fossilize why those things aren't after
them it was just standing in the bar
right
which is good what do I do how do I get
out of it
oh boy what do we do here we go okay
oh maybe this is the kind of one that I
would be able to put the meat down here
and now god damn it
wrong button okay I am screwing
everything up okay I have an idea for
that how to get around that um oh I need
to get this map first though that's
right yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah stop looking at with your
flashlight on come on Oh
done goofed very hard I done goo fall
over the place okay alright continuing
on a flashlight off hearing over here
gonna lose ya not dying but I I do die
it's okay cuz I save I'm gonna put meat
down here
placed me the dog on the night
go get the me God dang it okay that did
not work even a little bit I did not
work at all
hey how about you stop being a giant son
of a [ __ ] going to Oh everybody dies
huh huh I'm knock word guy standing in
the corner of the party I'm dancing
help me good I'm not talking about the
guy chillin and drinking I'm talking
about the guy that's just dancing by
himself in the corners
oh good time oh no good for you talk
what are you looking at you need to eat
something
you just had hot rice pudding excuse me
I didn't even know I can hear anything
above me whose Oh weird my stomach
growling oh is that my stomach growling
no it couldn't have it alright so anyway
this guy will not stop eating god this
guy will not relax with the food intake
but I'm gonna get I'm gonna cook him one
more thing and then I'm gonna go tena
beans squid on a stick
jeez guy cuz um milk bottle of milk
probably needs uh I'll actually have
that much food anymore I'll cook the tin
of beans and then go to sleep warm him
up although I haven't been that much
time but I'm coming to the end of this
episode so I gotta get gone gonna beans
got the warm beans
eatos means find them with the crackers
oh I thought that would have been I
would eat that are you never here beans
really are the survival staple of the
generations truth man listen Daisy
i'ma hit the bed I'm gonna hit hey now
I'm gonna get on out of here
cuz I am running over time with with a
wizard having to go through everything
before unfortunately I made a horrible
error didn't do much good are you
talking about
go ask yourself in the a okay right some
have you in the a nice day okay so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh what the [ __ ] hell Oh get out of
here
Oh I've had no help there's no help I
smack you
Julian time let's beat
look that cabinet on fire